YURI GRINSHTEYN: Errors in
your field are unavoidable,
and it's important to know
when they happen and get
enough information
to fix them quickly.
Writing out error
logs is easy enough,
but how do you send those
messages to Stackdriver?
Let's look at how to get
your logs into Stackdriver
and what you can do from there.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There are multiple ways to
log errors in Google Cloud.
You can use logging and set
your log severity to error
or you can use error reporting
to get powerful tracking
and analysis capabilities.
Today, I want to show
you how both work
and help you understand
how to choose between them.
Let's start with a simple
example of a web server
written in node.js.
The app encounters an error.
So something has
gone wrong, but we
don't have any other details.
You'll want to write those
details to an error log,
but there are a few
ways to do that.
Your first option is to use the
Cloud Logging Library directly.
However, it requires you to
explicitly build each log entry
by manually specifying your
metadata before writing it.
This can be useful if
you need this level
of fine-grained control
over the data you're writing
but could be tedious if
you're doing a lot of logging.
More commonly, you may choose
to either use the Bunyan
or Winston logging libraries.
To use the Bunyan library,
simply add it to your code,
create a new instance
of the logger,
and then write error logs
using the .error method.
Using the Winston
library is very similar.
Create a new instance of the
logger and write error logs
using the .error method.
In both cases,
structured logs will be
written to Stackdriver Logging.
The main difference between the
Bunyan and Winston libraries
is the verbosity of
the resulting logs.
The Bunyan log messages
contain a lot more metadata,
potentially making
them more useful,
but resulting in higher log
volumes and possibly higher
costs.
Consider both of
these factors when
choosing your logging approach.
So now we have a
way to log basic app
errors on our node server.
From here, we can do
things like create
log base metrics to be notified
when these errors occur.
But what happens if these
errors are actually exceptions
that contain stack traces?
If you log an exception,
the full stack trace
is available on the
log entry, making
it easy to understand
exactly what happened.
However, it's still hard
to get your information
across your exceptions.
This is where you can use
Stackdriver Error Reporting,
which automatically identifies
exceptions, groups them based
on the stack trace, and
creates a histogram showing you
when these exceptions occur.
There's no additional
setup needed
to get error reporting to
identify errors or stack traces
in them.
You can look at the
details of each error
to see the full stack trace and
the individual logger records
that contain that error.
You can then subscribe
to notifications
to know when new errors are
detected in your project
and link errors to
bugs to keep track
of errors you fixed over time.
Note that you can actually
use the error reporting client
to send errors directly
to error reporting,
even if they don't
have stack traces.
If you do that,
they're also written
to Stackdriver Logging
along with other logs
you write, allowing you to reap
the benefits of both logging
and error reporting.
You have multiple options for
writing errors and exceptions
to Stackdriver Logging,
and using error reporting
can be a good way to get a
better understanding of how
and when crashes
happen in your app
without giving up the
benefits of logging.
Thank you for joining me today,
and come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]